[Music]
on this thursday night deadly delay
there was numerous officers
at that classroom numerous concerns
officers wasted precious seconds in
uvalde plus they went in front of my
classmates to help to save them a
survivor shares his story of heroic
teachers
tracing monkey parks where the outbreak
started and the search for new cases
housing sticker shock it is a bit
heartbreaking that things are the way
that they are the right of passage
that's increasingly out of reach
and goodbye to a good fella
really funny
the shocking death of acting legend ray
liotta
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thank you for joining
us dramatic and disturbing new details
are emerging about the way police
responded to a shooter at that
elementary school in uvalde texas with
one young survivor recounting the terror
he experienced and the heroism he
witnessed and when i heard the shooting
through the door
i told my friend to hide under something
so they so he won't find us we have a
door in the middle and he opened it and
then he came in and he crouched a little
bit and he said it's time to die they
were nice teachers and
they
they went in front of my classmates to
help to save them
as we hear those
harrowing stories from young survivors
we're also learning more about how the
horror unfolded on tuesday jackson
proskow joins us now live from uvalde
texas tonight with more jackson
chris the trauma experienced by so many
is really coming into focus with those
horrific stories from those young
children who are inside that schoolhouse
but of course we know it's not just
limited to those who are in the school
it impacts the entire community a
community that will likely never be the
same
what was supposed to have been the last
day of the school year became a day of
mourning at robb elementary where people
came to lay flowers and pray before 21
white crosses
i just want to stop i want justice
it is impossible to comprehend the level
of grief or the horrors witnessed by the
children who survived i just read like
three or four or five gunshots like
nine-year-old adeline garza hid in a
second grade classroom while the gunman
was in a neighboring room full of
students
two of her cousins were shot but
survived
my cousin she got shot on her nose and
her neck
like the balloon went through her
[Music]
during the nearly one hour the gunman
was inside the school parents rushed to
the building ready to put themselves in
harm's way to rescue their children
they were held back by police as they
begged to get inside
my cousin my uncle tried to go to go get
her but
tackled him like two times the police
response is now under growing scrutiny
the gunman entered the school without
needing any resistance the first
officers to arrive say they were pushed
back by gunfire for the next hour they
say they attempted negotiations and
rescued other students while the shooter
stayed in that classroom could anybody
have gone there sooner do you understand
small town
yeah people from eagle pass
from del rio
laredo san antonio responding
[Music]
questions now haunt this community why
did this happen what more could have
been done to stop it
but answers will not bring back what has
been lost
thoughts and prayers offer little
comfort
the anger palpable for those who've long
fought for gun reform how do you explain
to americans that this does not happen
in other countries
i don't have to explain anything to
anybody they
we all know that this is not right
this doesn't happen anywhere else on the
planet
this is completely of our making and our
choosing
we know that u.s president joe biden
will visit yuvaldi on sunday it's the
second such trip he's had to make to the
scene of a mass shooting in as many
weeks and of course chris the prospects
for him getting anything done
politically are slim because of the
gridlock that awaits him when he returns
to washington that's the worst part of
all of this um you touched on it a
little bit in your report jackson but we
got a lot more detail about the timeline
of the police response today take us
through what we learned today and why
people are concerned about it
that's right it's this one hour between
the initial police response when the
gunman entered the building and his
eventual death that is drawing a lot of
scrutiny let's walk you through the
timeline here that we got from police
today at 11 28 a.m police say that the
suspect crashed a pickup truck that he
had stolen from his grandmother remember
she was his first victim shot in the
face and she called 9-1-1 she did
survive after that crash the suspect ran
from the vehicle with a rifle and a bag
of ammunition he fired on two nearby
witnesses near the school missing both
and 12 minutes later 11 40 a.m he
entered rob's
elementary school and started firing
four minutes after that local police and
the school district police entered the
school they came under heavy fire
retreated and requested backup and one
hour later it was a member of the u.s
border patrol's tactical team that then
entered the school and shot and killed
him and again chris we know that during
that time there were evacuations of
students underway but many people
wondering what more could have been done
in that precious hour that was lost
still so many questions to be answered
thank you very much jackson jackson
proskow and yuvaldi tonight
as the uvalde community mourns those
killed in the deadly shooting several
more children are still fighting for
their lives in hospital and some of the
most seriously injured were taken to san
antonio that's where heather yorick's
west is for us tonight heather
chris san antonio's university hospital
is a level one pediatric trauma hospital
and they have been through mass
shootings before so teams were at the
ready when the call came in about what
happened in uvalde and while there are
some young patients still being treated
by trauma teams here today in sirius and
critical condition
many of the victims never made it this
far
among the many tragic losses in yuvaldi
there are also incredible stories of
survival quick thinking saved
11-year-old mia cirillo's life mia
got some blood and put it on herself
where she can pretend that she was dead
the fourth grader was injured and taken
to hospital but later released left now
to heal from an emotional trauma greater
than any child her age should have to
face this is going to bring up all kinds
of fear fear of going to school fear of
the world fear of safety
why aren't adults doing something about
it this is part of their life fabric now
so this experience will never go away
at university hospital in san antonio
three little girls ages 9 and 10 remain
in hospital listed in critical but
stable condition doctors credit the
lessons from another mass shooting for
saving their lives the reason why we
feel like we have survivors from this
incident
related to what we learned from
sutherland springs unfortunately we
learned from sutherland springs in that
shooting five years ago 26 people died
including eight children and an unborn
baby when a gunman opened fire at a
south texas church medical trauma teams
here never imagined they'd face the same
horror a second time
it's why so many in this heartbroken
community are doing whatever they can to
lend a hand it's really devastating i
think all of texas is probably
pretty heartbroken right now about what
happened now there is some hopeful news
here doctors say some of the patients
may be able to be released later this
week so they can continue their recovery
at home with their families but the
physical and emotional scars may be with
these kids forever chris
no doubt all right that's heather
yorick's west in san antonio tonight
thank you heather
multiple schools were put into lockdown
in toronto this afternoon after reports
of a man with a gun near an elementary
school police officers ended up shooting
and killing the suspect officers
responded to calls about a man walking
with a rifle that's when the schools
were put on alert the police chief says
he can't speculate on a motive at this
time ontario's police watchdog has now
taken over the investigation
public health officials continue to
watch for more monkey pox cases in
canada with one confirmed in toronto and
25 in quebec but giving out more
information about these cases is proving
to be controversial jamie morocco has
more on the stigma surrounding the virus
each day the number of confirmed lab
tests for monkey pox continues to grow
in quebec officials are fast tracking
vaccination plans it's a serious health
break outbreak of monkey pucks a single
dose of the smallpox vaccine known to be
effective against monkey pox can help if
given within four days of exposure so
far the quebec patients are men between
20 and 30 years old with one under 18.
doctors tell global news the suspected
origin of the province's outbreak is a
sauna in montreal dr robert polarsky
treated one of the first cases
he actually got it from g.i jio so this
is the suspected epicenter of the
epidemic a detail quebec health
officials would not confirm concerned it
would stigmatize the community but
experts worry holding key information
back from the public is problematic i
think hiding it then makes it even come
out another way which is that
um men having sex with men is
bad i think it really does speak to this
broader culture where we're
uncomfortable with the idea of sex
and we're uncomfortable talking about
sex monkey box is not considered a
sexually transmitted infection but does
spread as a result of close prolonged
personal contact it can also survive on
surfaces like bedding toronto public
health was quick to name two local clubs
connected to its first case of monkey
pox axis and woodies bioethicist carrie
bowman says these details matter i would
argue it is important to identify where
it's coming from because you know if you
don't then people are not in a position
to protect themselves in montreal's
village some sauna patrons say they
haven't seen warnings about the virus
others say employees are encouraging
increased safety measures
they really want to diminish the
propagation he says of not only the
virus but stigma and hate too
jamie morocco global news toronto
two captured russian soldiers pleaded
guilty today to shelling a town in
eastern ukraine during the second war
crimes trial of the conflict the kremlin
still denies its targeting civilians but
as jeff semple shows us ukraine says
it's found evidence of more than 10
thousand possible war crimes and
identified at least 600 suspects
on the morning of march 15th ola went
looking for her son
and this is what she found
the charred remains of his vehicle and
her son in the driver's seat
i put my son's remains into a bag and
carried them on my back she says
she then walked 15 kilometers to bury
him here in the backyard
[Music]
her son's friend told her they were
driving a shipment of aid to their
russian occupied town when they were
attacked by a russian tank
she returned to the scene this week
joined by a team of police and forensics
experts tasked with investigating
russian war crimes
the prosecutor says they're
investigating more than a dozen war
crimes on the outskirts of harkev all
involving civilians killed well under
russian occupation
a war crime is any instance where
civilians are deliberately targeted for
example this apartment building blown
apart by two bombs allegedly dropped by
a russian warplane nine people were
killed and this is now being
investigated as a possible war crime
residents say the bomb's impact
shattered windows and turned shards of
glass into projectiles
my grandchildren were covered in blood
they were rushed to the hospital this
resident says
along with targeting civilians war
crimes can also be linked to a
particular weapon
in this town a few hours south the mayor
shows us neighborhoods riddled with
these shrapnel pellets like the kind
found in cluster munitions
cluster bombs typically disperse in the
air spreading smaller bombs
indiscriminately over a large area
they're banned by most countries but
global news saw evidence of cluster
submunitions in several areas
[Applause]
the whole town is like this the mayor
says with a pre-war population of nine
thousand barbinkova has no military
infrastructure or strategic value
eleven people have been killed here
including children
they're targeting civilians the mayor
says there isn't a single street in our
town where homes haven't been hit
on this nearby road a resident returned
to find her house destroyed she
collected these fragments from a russian
rocket
i don't understand why the russians are
doing this she said we will never
forgive them
jeff semple global news harkev ukraine
game over before it even began coming up
why canada is canceling its soccer match
with iran plus the man leading a
monumental forensic investigation at
former residential schools
the discovery of 215 suspected unmarked
graves on the grounds of the former
kamloops indian residential school last
year shocked many canadians even those
survivors and elders have known about it
for decades the tecumulups to schwepp
mcfirst nation is trying to identify and
repatriate the remains but nitu garcia
shows us it's a monumental undertaking
that could take years so i'll counter
the numbers in blackfoot
one nituka two nato
eldon yellowhorn is an indigenous
studies professor in bc and an
archaeologist he started researching
burials near canada's residential
schools in 2009 there was just not as
much
attention paid to these
cases
the harper government denied the truth
and reconciliation commission's request
for funds to find the graves in 2012
sioux valley dakota nation in manitoba
started its own search which yellowhorn
has been a part of we have identified
104
burials in the cemetery
and we've been working on this project
since 2019 so we're actually quite well
ahead
advanced in our research
and to date we've been able to recover
the identities of 98 of the children who
are buried in that cemetery they've done
it using archives and oral histories
which yellowhorn hopes can also help
identify children from the hundreds of
unmarked burials near kamloops this is
not something that's going to happen in
one or two years
in fact
i would say we should be planning for 30
or 40 years
here in bc the rcmp has opened a file
with to come loops to schwetmick as the
lead official nationally starting this
year the rcmp will be getting 5.1
million in funding in part to create
four new positions to improve
relationships with indigenous
communities and support their
investigations it could be three to four
thousand
individual kids in graves across the
country for yellowhorn helping families
find answers has a deeply personal
connection his father was an orphan who
grew up in a residential school i never
realized that he attended that school
until i was working at the national
archives in ottawa and i found a letter
where he was enrolled into that school
and that's part of the reason why he's
hoping to partner with more communities
conducting this research and potentially
pursuing criminal accountability needu
garcia global news to come loops to
schweitman
and a reminder of the support available
for survivors of residential schools and
their families the number is toll free
on your screen it operates 24 hours a
day 1-800-721-0066
canada soccer is cancelling a
controversial men's match against iran
it was to be played june 5th in
vancouver team canada is preparing for
the world cup later this year in the
past week though canada soccer says the
match became significantly divisive
canada holds iran responsible for
shooting down a passenger plane in 2020
killing everyone on board including 85
canadians prime minister justin trudeau
said last week the match was not quote a
very good idea
priced out how a whole generation of
canadians faces an uphill battle to buy
a home
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
the canadian housing market was red-hot
before the pandemic but over the last
couple of years it's gone stratospheric
here's ann gaviola now with part three
of her sticker shock series the impact
of housing inflation
thirty-three-year-old tembeca pratt has
dreamt of homeownership for a decade it
is a bit
heartbreaking that things are the way
that they are and you know the prices
are a little bit
much together she and her fiance make
nearly two hundred thousand dollars
annually they're more than average
earners but with an upcoming wedding to
save for and home prices on a tear
during the pandemic she's frustrated her
prospects seem bleaker than ever in
toronto where the average house price is
more than 1.3 million dollars the annual
income needed to afford that is 228 000.
the average condo is more than 720 000
which requires nearly 145 000 a year a
young person making a typical amount of
money must now work 17 years across
canada to afford a 20 down payment for
an average priced home in metro
vancouver and the greater toronto area
it takes 27 years ottawa 14 years it
took just five years in the mid 70s
deputy pm christian freeland calls it
intergenerational injustice we
had
a better shot
at buying a home and starting a family
than young people today
with interest rates rising to combat
inflation home prices have taken a
little breather but they're still up by
about 50 percent across the country to
bridge that gap incomes either have to
skyrocket or home prices need to come
down to earth in the world of politics
and our economy housing has become this
moment where what's benefited parents
and grandparents has hurt their children
and grandchildren more than just an
appreciating asset for newcomers and
young workers home ownership is a rite
of passage they may never reach
it's something that
will outlive you and can create
generational wealth ann caviola global
news toronto
next one of hollywood's good fellas is
gone remembering tough guy actor ray
liotta
ray liotta is one of hollywood's biggest
names star of goodfellas and field of
dreams known for his tough talking
characters and charismatic screen
presence his sudden death at 67 comes as
a big shock and mike trolley takes a
look back at leota's stellar career
let's go
you're going to regret this
your life's full of regrets no
you are really going to be praising this
what we never regretted was ray liotta
on screen that glare he shot kevin
costner
mesmerizing it didn't matter who else
was in the scene leota could find a way
to stand out
you're a funny guy that role in
goodfellas opened doors the rest of his
career even if he didn't fully
understand his appeal i just want to
play pretend that's it that's what i
like that's what i like about this leota
was new jersey born and seemingly born
for the roles he'd be cast and type cast
in
so much tragedy in your life
lorraine bracko who played his wife in
goodfellas said the best part of making
the movie was ray seth rogan his co-star
in observant report called him a lovely
talented and hilarious person
he certainly was
could i come back again
oh if only you could ray
if only you could
that is global national for this
thursday i'm chris galas tonight's your
canada is atlan british columbia where
locals like to boast it's the most
beautiful place on earth
thanks very much for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow night have a
great night